our top story business owners are
slashing at boyars get a new healthcare
look for adverse news of a missing white
person but wake up in the morning ten
minutes later hit the snooze like Chris
Brown data brush all my teeth and
driving and along the way but I'm bored
when I walk into the joint I'm more
confused and Joe Namath with a corn my
boss's memo says starting today I'm
working one to five my hours keep on
falling down nah
and the creditors keep calling said I
could keep my plane I'm no longer a
believer do deductible so how you think
it's dad whatever movie
once you buy not trying to be
controversial but I'm home and I'm
watching JG Wentworth commercials say
good pass full time and hello to
underemployment because I'm working I'm
working
you know I'm no longer out there tall
and
is less complete than Assoc Paulette for
the New York Times telling me it's
liberating
what is it critter I guess employee
compensation
[Music]
I'm insecure and broke-ass right where
like the Obamacare website working
weren't you fine it's just simple tasks
it's like
line directly on fire
[Music]